I've got yet another story to tell you
about a drone being shot down this time
by a 65 year old woman in rural Northern
Virginia who has lived this woman
jennifer Youngman has lived in the
plains Virginia since 1990 and she said
she came back from church on a Sunday
morning and she was cleaning and she was
cleaning shotguns which I guess is not
that rare in the plains Virginia I mean
it sounds kind of right both a 4 10 and
a 20 gauge on her porch she had a clear
view of the beautiful mountains and all
of a sudden next thing you know she says
that there's a thing going down her
field and it's buzzing and it's scaring
her cows and it's wreaking all kinds of
havoc it was a drone it disappeared over
the trees and hey since she was already
cleaning her shotguns she heard the
noise coming back and then ultimately
shot the drone down police were involved
all sorts of chaos happened and this is
not going to be that rare of a happening
I think in the future
now you're probably going to see more
drones in the more urban areas where
guns are typically gun ownership is
maybe less common flying a drone out in
the middle of nowhere is kind of
difficult because there's also a way
fewer people in the middle of nowhere to
be flying drones I think this is
definitely not the last we've heard of
shooting drones down I'm just interested
in interested in the precedent set here
court wise and by the police whose fault
is this right is the real question here
I think and a lot of this gets into the
the real estate law area of air rights
and the discussion of how far into the
air above your property is it your
property and this is an issue I remember
taking a real estate law class when I
was in graduate school and this was one
of the issues that came up this was pre
drunk when this is before drones were
even common but more about what if
someone were to have a very very long
fishing line where they were dangling
something from a taller building over
your building or whatever
at what point right with drones the
examples are way way simpler right
but this idea of air rights above one's
property like with the internet like
with so many different areas of law the
law is going to need to catch up to the
reality that drones are going to be
increasingly common we're seeing pizza
delivery already happening in Australia
via drone delivery etc etc this is going
to be an issue and I don't know the the
the part that scares me it's very often
the laws on new areas of law are years
and years behind how the real world is
actually working and if we get some
decisions in courts that set precedent
before this is really well thought out
we might have some really bad precedent
set on this area so I'm interested what
is the actual law regarding real estate
there I'm not actually sure ok I think
it depends I mean of course I'm not a
lawyer not that anybody would would
think that I was but I I don't know if
it varies from state to state if it
varies depending on the situation we
know that in terms of the FAA and
altitudes that there the idea that is
being thought of for drones is there's
an exclusion zone around airports where
airplanes would be flying low and then
outside of that there would be a ceiling
for drone operation which would be below
where you would have planes operating at
you know maybe 1,500 feet or something
like that and that as a rule the takeoff
and landing of drones would have to be
completely vertical right so that
there's no chance of as you are getting
up to your required altitude you're sort
of diagonally tracing a path through
areas where you shouldn't be I think
that from what I've read that's the
consensus of how drones should be forced
to operate yeah so I'm actually up to
dating laws myself I'm planning on
getting my remote pilot certification
which is the new certification allowed
as of the 29th of this month mm-hmm so
the law is you actually can fly in these
air spaces around airports but you have
to get written permission from the air
traffic controller there absolutely and
I recently read that someone wanted to
get so the city of Boston physically is
so close to Logan Airport that if you're
trying to do any drone photography in
the downtown area you were within that I
don't know how many miles is it within
the airport three five miles something
like that I think it's like one and a
half or two I could be wrong okay
so you actually have to get permission
from Logan Airport even just to do some
of these drone shots around the city and
I was recently reading about somebody
who had to do that yeah it's interesting
and then I know you you can only fly up
to 250 feet I'm not and the other law it
and really which concerns City is in
Boston etc is that you can't fly over
people which is one of these gray areas
that people are talking about what is
over person is it this little space here
or is it you know yeah what is the
personal space that is described as
being over a person yeah this is exactly
what we're talking about when we say
that the technology often get in the
real world gets way ahead of where the
law is and then you have to sort of
figure these things out we will let you
know what ultimately happens and I'm
sure we'll hear from Jason about his
experience